what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas Youk and welcome back to the
channel today we're gonna be talking all
things Apple but before we get into it
I'd like to announce that my case for my
pre-ordered Samsung s20 ultra has
arrived but the actual phone has not so
this thing is kind of pointless to me
for the next couple weeks till it gets
shipped on the 5th of March and
hopefully arrives on the 6th of March
where I'll be doing a full unboxing
review and a couple camera comparisons
for you guys so if that's something that
interests you smash that subscribe
button and let's get started alright so
recently we've had a pretty major leak
talking about that Apple earpods X now
this is a bit of a confusing one because
when we say air pods we always think the
little small air buds that go in our
ears but it looks like apples actually
going to be creating the full beats by
dre style over the ear headphones what
we've seen so far is a target leak
stating that they're gonna be 399 USD
which comes in about 550 almost 600
Australian and we've also seen some very
unrealistic renders of what it might
look like now I'm gonna keep this video
really short and sharp and straight to
the point because I'm truly not feeling
also crash hot today but I really want
to get some information out to you guys
and stick to my see you next Monday cash
line that I've had for over a year now
moving on to the next item we talked
about the brand new MacBook Pro coming
out in mid to late 2020
the only thing rumored so far that's
pretty much been almost a confirmed
rumor is the fact that they're bumping
it up from an 8th generation Intel Core
chip to a 10th generation Intel Core
chip which is a pretty big leap forward
because this is rumored to be in the
very beginning intro model so the
cheapest MacBook you can buy it will
come in with a much much better
processor than the
one that you can buy right now off the
shelf and finally something everybody is
going to be asking about coming later
this year is the brand new iPhone 11s or
the iPhone 12 depending how they go but
based on previous history patterns were
probably going to be seeing the iPhone
11s before we see an iPhone 12 anytime
soon but basically what we're going to
get here is pretty much identical to
what we've just seen in the s20 ultra
they're going to be bringing out
something that is targeted at the
photography videography community with a
pro version name from Apple that will
more than likely be just as good as the
s20 ultra but if I'm being a little bit
of a fanboy towards a person I don't see
it happening in this s11 s release it's
more than likely going to be coming out
in next year's model so 2021 with the
iPhone 12 if you're a tech guru make
sure that you do check out the s20 ultra
when it is officially unveiled to the
public and everybody can get their hands
on them because I personally believe the
current comparison between an s2000
truck and an iPhone 11 Pro Maxx is
pretty much a huge game-changer for
Samsung that a KVD recording looks
pretty good at cheap and a little bit
out rigid in my personal opinion from
what I've seen so far but 4k to 4k
comparison with a hundred and eight
megapixel sensor on the s20 Ultra is
definitely something to be considering
if you don't want to wait for the s12
for the iPhone 12 to come out in two and
a bit years time anyway that's all I
have for you guys today thanks so much
for watching I'm gonna go straight to
bed because I am feeling terrible but
hopefully I'm gonna feel a little bit
better next Monday with a small great
tech information for you guys so as
always I'll see you next Monday